[Music]
death it's an excellent topic of
conversation because it's so relatable
after all it's bound to happen to all of
us well except dr bright sorry jack the
leading causes of death for most normal
people are heart disease cancer
accidents and strokes but for people
working at the scp foundation or those
unlucky enough to have brushes with the
anomalous in civilian life the wheel of
misfortune has plenty more options for
your inevitable demise we're not talking
about boring deaths like being eaten by
a giant killer reptile or being
disintegrated on an atomic level by a
giant winged guardian with a sword
hotter than the sun the truly sticky
ends we're talking about today will make
weak sauce fatalities like that look
like passing away peacefully in your
sleep prepare for a big warm spoonful of
existential terror because this is the
worst ways to die
scp foundation edition let's kick off
this carnival of death with an old
friend of ours uncle larry himself as
cp106
also known as the old man this scp
celebrity is infamous for two things his
ability to walk through solid objects
and his absolute adoration for causing
pain
seriously this is a guy who loves
torturing people so much that he has his
own pocket dimension specifically
tailored for the grisly task that's why
if you fall into his greasy black claws
you've got an utterly nightmarish death
in store for you expect to be tortured
and mutilated over an extremely long
period of time his greatest hits include
pulling out your teeth shoving his
fingers or even arms into your body and
of course melting you thankfully a lot
of the finer details of what this freak
does to his victims are either redacted
or not recorded probably for the sake of
all of our collective sanities but for
some context one of his recovered
victims looked like this the worst part
he was still alive when that photo was
taken sleep tight or alternatively don't
because if you have
scp-966 on your tail you won't be
sleeping at all these nasty little
gremlins are called the sleep killers
which is somewhat ironic because as part
of their protracted stalking and hunting
period they disable their victims
ability to sleep picture that invisible
monsters keeping you awake forever
leading to a period of deadly insomnia
you'll become tired but you'll never
know rest you'll start hallucinating
you'll get weak everyone around you will
just think you're very sick and they'll
probably recommend everything from
nyquil to valyrian root but none of that
will help nothing will help technically
you're a walking corpse already and just
when you think it can't get any worse
when your mind has practically been
turned to soup in your head by the sleep
deprivation that's when the sleep
killers will finally strike they'll
attack tear you to pieces and eat you
alive you will have gone through your
own personal hell and nobody will ever
know what happened to you say speaking
of personal hells and long dramatic
deaths lets mosey on over to our next
horrific method of spin kicking off the
mortal coil scp-439
also known as the bone hive if you're
familiar with this nasty customer
already then i'm sorry you're about to
go through this nightmare again but for
the rest of you this scp is a species of
tiny silver earwigs with some truly
unique breeding and nesting habits
namely they make their nests out of
living people the queen of their
colonies will crawl into your body while
you're sleeping leading to what seems at
first like a nasty cough and some bodily
aches and pains these soon become so
agonizing that you're paralyzed you'll
lock yourself into a small dark place at
which point the rapidly breeding earwigs
inside you will start to convert your
body into a huge calcium hive they'll
turn your internal organs into breeding
centers and food sources you'll be alive
through all of this too why because your
living body acts as an internal heating
system you will die in the end if that's
any consolation of starvation wow what a
bummer right i think we could all use a
good laugh after that last one
thankfully we've got scp-2030 also known
as laugh is fun to deliver some levity
into this otherwise dire situation 2030
is probably the ultimate hardcore hidden
camera show where the terrifying
anomalous pranks often lead to their
victims meeting gruesome ends while
their victims and surrounding bystanders
often find these nightmarish deaths
weirdly funny the ends that 20 30 dishes
out are enough to turn your stomach here
are a few examples for you just to wet
or permanently destroy your appetite an
old woman feeding pigeons in the park
had a hundred pigeons fly down her
throat bursting her stomach open a man
was flayed alive and had his skin filled
with live squirrels a woman was attacked
by a lump of flesh shaped like an
amalgamation of margaret thatchers which
then shoved its tongue down her throat
causing her body to be transformed into
a collection of margaret thatcher faces
too and the scariest thing is that all
of these victims technically died by
more normal means already that's right
everyone who stars in this twisted show
is already dead before they ever make
their appearance their restless souls
drawn into the nightmare of scp-2030
where they're killed again in even worse
ways
maybe that wasn't pleasant let's instead
talk about the baby no not duh baby
we're talking about scp-734
the baby let's go this cute little baby
seems innocent enough and in terms of
his personality he is however the bodily
fluids of this baby can give you a truly
sickening death if you come into contact
with the baby's fluids you'll begin to
experience what first seems like an
aggressive skin condition pain itching
and redness this will then lead to even
more unpleasant and painful skin flaking
which will soon begin to expand over
your body eating away at you more and
more the flaking will get wider and
deeper your organs and bones will start
to disintegrate little by little you'll
painfully fall to pieces over a number
of hours by the time you're dead you'll
look like a big pile of bloody dandruff
needless to say it's incredibly
unpleasant speaking of big unpleasant
piles let's talk about the horrifying
death you can get courtesy of scp-162
also known by an appropriately ominous
name the ball of sharp this thing is so
deadly that it's one of the many scps
that the foundation has tried to use to
terminate scp-682
it's an eight-foot tall pile of fish
hooks fish line needles scissors and
almost every other sharp pointy object
you can imagine you've heard of a needle
in the haystack well meet the needle
stack where the hay is you and scariest
of all this scp has a cognito hazardous
effect of brainwashing you into wanting
to jump into its spiky embrace and if
you jump into the ball of sharp well
what the heck do you think happens
you'll get poked and stabbed and cut
horrifically and because of the cognito
hazardous effects you'll alternate
between complaining about horrific pain
to talking about how much you love it
and would like to be left alone with a
ball and of course in the end you'll
either bleed to death or die of extreme
body trauma yay
you know if you really think about it
the ball of sharp seems a little like an
avant-garde modern art piece perhaps
it's a commentary on how much it sucked
to get thrown into a giant ball of
pointy objects speaking of art and
things that suck it really sucked to be
murdered by
scp-1155 the predatory street art this
horrific two-dimensional predator is a
piece of evil graffiti that preys on
solitary victims who happen to stray too
close to its grasp and the predatory
street art is a monster so gratuitously
violent he'd probably get along really
well with uncle larry it won't just kill
and eat you like a standard predator
it'll kill you chop you up and put your
body parts in its gory cupboard in order
to eat you as a midnight snack later and
while this is a gruesome way to go it's
still nothing compared to the sheer
mind-bending horror that getting killed
by the next anomaly will bring christmas
only comes once a year and
scp-4666 also known as the yule man will
make you extremely grateful for that
this living nightmare of an anomaly only
operates over a 12-day period during the
christmas season and if you happen to be
on this sadistic santa's naughty list
you're probably in for a horrible fate
that is literally beyond what we're able
to fully describe here to give you some
perspective if you're lucky he'll just
murder you and your entire family in one
evening normally using torture
mutilation and cannibalism and if you're
unlucky and also underage then the yule
man will take you down to his workshop
where you'll act as his slave and spend
the rest of your life making morbid toys
and then if you're the luckiest among
the unlucky he'll take you aside and eat
you when he's feeling hungry if not
he'll work you until your body breaks
then force your fellow workers to
convert you into a toy while you're
still alive
that's right if you're not fit enough to
keep slaving away and make the toys
you'll literally be made into the toys
needless to say you certainly won't be
having a merry christmas okay that was a
little intense maybe we should take a
seat and relax for a second wait where's
my chair this is just a pile of wood
chips oh i see it's scp-1609
the remains of a chair what's this doing
in the video we're making a video on
gruesome deaths we don't need a goofy
pile of wood chips throwing everything
okay okay
okay i'm sorry i won't talk down to you
again i should have remembered when
scp-1609 feels threatened it teleports
wood chips and metal fragments into the
lungs of its victim tearing them apart
from within and leading to their victims
choking to death on their own blood come
to think of it this probably does
deserve to be on the list of the worst
deaths and finally we've got scp-149
also known as the blood flies to the
untrained eye these nasty little suckers
are just mosquitos non-anomalous
mosquitoes might give you malaria if
you're unlucky but outside of that the
worst thing you'll probably get from
these guys is an itchy bite mark that's
definitely not the case for scp-149
if one of these creatures bites you
you're infected with a retrovirus that
mutates regenerating human cells into
fertilized mosquito eggs we're off to a
rough start already but it gets worse
within a five hour period the victim is
covered in large hard cysts filled with
live mosquito larvae by this point
they've reached full maturation and
begin to exit the body on mass through
the nose mouth and eye sockets infection
by scp-149 is fatal and the chance of
infection has been estimated to be 50
percent from one bite it almost has you
wishing for malaria and there you have
it folks some of the most horrific ways
you can die at the hands of some of the
monsters objects and concepts from the
scp foundation but if we're being
totally honest with you that's barely
even scratching the surface
there are so many awful ways to die in
the scp universe it'd almost be
impossible to cover them in one video if
you want to see more horrifying scp
deaths let us know down in the comments
if of course you live that long now go
check out evil monster created by the
scp foundation
scp-2419 the laughing men and
irresistible pickup artist
scp-3512 the more you know for more scp
foundation scenarios that'll give you
nightmares